así que está muy buenos dias valentina
pues lo cierto es que aquí el centro de
la ciudad de minneapolis fue un
auténtico clamor segundos después de que
se conociera ese resultado del veredicto
de los doce miembros del jurado de
mayoría blanca que culpaban a derecho
de los tres cargos a los que se
enfrentaban lo hemos visto al presidente
de eeuu joe biden
decir que se siente reconfortado por
este veredicto pero dice que no es
suficiente para combatir en lo que
considera que es el que es el racismo
sistémico que hay en eeuu por eso se
compromete se comprometió a impulsar
reformas reales y también pidió un
cambio en la legislación que regula a la
policía en el país norteamericano
también habló recogió las palabras de la
hija de george floyd diana diciendo que
su padre había cambiado el mundo y él
dijo que eso era sólo el principio
también el ex presidente barack obama
también
y reconfortado con esa decisión del
jurado dijo que ellos habían hecho lo
correcto pero que la justicia de verdad
requiere cambios mucho más profundos es
la opinión que también compartían otras
personas que se congregaban aquí en los
exteriores del centro de gobernación
donde se llevó a cabo en estas tres
semanas el juicio a derecho vil y
también el gobernador de minnesota tim
world dijo que esto era sólo el
principio para ir adelante hacia un
cambio